yeah welcome to this video I'm playing
sky 1016 and this is not the US yeah
this is Malaysia or something probably
yeah malaysia I got one right okay so
I'm very high rating for a player player
from Malaysia no naming them I don't
think they have maybe one or two I am
NOT not sure I'm not may be confusing
things yeah I that's one Chinese player
sank song funny funny name um he's
loving is he in Malaysia was a Singapore
I don't know he am he left China for one
of those countries so a very quick h4 h5
hmm i think this is fairly uncommon
usually do you got the night here first
and maybe I can play Queen g5 and this
is the reason why nobody plays that way
check okay take g6 no we can take g6
rook h1 g7 know you could have taken g6
rook h1g seven yeah okay this is and I
don't know what this is but the other
one was son yeah probably a killing Wow
okay he just uses the king
I go night e 72 f 5 a-8 p is going to
play G for him I could theoretically
plane ig8
oops okay let's I need I need more
pieces in and play wow I could have just
taken on g6 this is cool yeah let's
let's threaten with them counterplay
taking an ID before
check
okay i know the edge born but i need
some some player for my own
I take him in probably probably bad
Bishop to a 4mm doesn't turn doesn't
really help you go see three I take at
the end I probably don't have don't have
enough play there's always this pawn if
he goes Knight f3 and takes g5 I mean
I'm in really bad shape
okay but I need to need to play play
something b4 b5 before they're probably
just not a three takes d5 and I'm gone
I invest quite some time to get rid of
my play here I think he could have just
played night at 32 g g5 perform Oh Kim I
know it is very ugly but I cannot allow
him to take it's not a matter of the
porn but the Sun I couldn't act and
couldn't allow that maybe I can can get
get the porn but it is very very ugly
chest
I status chicken he got this check whoa
what a howler check
yeah it's the some way to to fight him
yeah that son try one last really cheap
trick when he's taking too long he will
spot this very cheap the shop g6 trick
yeah he spotted it I know it was a very
cheap trick yeah that's not even much
potential form for cheaper
yeah come on let's let's resign that
black resigns yeah I mean okay then the
big one thing he could have just one
worth taking on Jake's my yeah just this
end resigns it's quite easy I only
spotted it too late Luke h1g 78 over
it's just the promotion so he didn't see
that check and this also means that this
is complete complete rubbish okay okay
but here we probably why this is better
anyway but here I probably can can
improve at some point maybe f6 here or
something yeah f6c I try to he's not
well developed this is the only thing
going for me maybe I need to do this now
trying for four activity yeah but it
screwed up it screwed up this 25 was bad
for technical reasons the capture that
he didn't seem and also what he played
was always better for white I have no
real way to to save this now this is
just too bad the structure alright
thanks for watching